l'époque guy d'aline sera toujours une
belle époque et ce talent nous le voyons
est plate et sur tous ces magnifiques
affiches dont vous avez fait le don
généreux à la sncf et je tiens à vous en
remercier particulièrement vous êtes
venu mettre au chemin de fer par l'amour
de la gare de perpignan
dans une rencontre historique et il est
bien certain que les biographes de
l'avenir retiendront cette rencontre
comme une étape marquante de voir leurs
yeux ce quartier encore une fois je vous
dis très simplement notre gratitude et
notre joie de boire dany peindre maurice
mann fait comme chez moi
je dois être le seul il une question qui
a été un peu trouverez ces derniers
jours à propos de mon attitude vis-à-vis
de la société de consommation le cigalon
a dit in exactement comme attali de
davie vis-à-vis de la société de
consommation était de 2000 $ l'heure ce
n'est pas exact c'est dix mille dollars
la minute
mais pour l'état de même qu'un il ya
deux ans j'avais donné tous les entrées
dans mon exposition pour la
reconstitution du musée de versailles
pour les tailles différentes de la gare
de perpignan
ce ton cadeau